اليوم س نطلع عبر الخريطه التفاعليه على
مواقع التوغل الاسرائيلي استمرار التوغل
الاسرائيلي ازدياد هذا اي التوغل في مناطق
جنوبي قطاع غزه لكن في المقابل في اطار
هذا التحليل سناتي على الاضاءه او ناتي
للاضاءه على عمليات المقاومه كتائب القسام
في مناطق التوغل تحديدا باستهداف ل اليات
وحشود عسكريه اسرائيليه هذا التحليل سيكون
كالعاده مع اللواء فيز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي لكن في البدايه مع
الزميل محمود الكن نطلع على تفاصيل
التحركات الميدانيه عبر الخارطه التفاعليه
محمود نعم حسن اليوم هناك توغلات جديده
نتحدث عن جبهتين جبهه الشمال وجبهه الجنوب
بالنسبه لقطاع غزه ه هنا نشاهد كامل قطاع
غزه كنا قد تحدثنا عن مناطق توغلات رئيسيه
في شمال القطاع تلعب كفكي كماشه هنا في
شمال مدينه غزه وجنوب مدينه غزه ويضاف الى
ذلك التوغل بالقرب من خان يونس هنا باتجاه
محور صلاح الدين لكن دعونا اولا نتجه الى
شمال قطاع غزه هنا نشاهد هذه المناطق
التوغل الجديد هنا عندما اظهر هذه الاسماء
هو ب اتجاهين شمال الشجاعيه من الشرق
وجنوب الشجاعيه كذلك من الشرق قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تحاول هذا اليوم وهو
التطور الابرز التوغل من هذه المناطق
باتجاه حي الشجاعيه الان حي الشجاعيه هو
من اقوى مناطق الارتكاز لدى قوات الدفاع
قوات المقاومه هنا في هذه النقطه وكان
طبعا كان احد محاور الاستهدافات في عام
2014 بالتالي محاولات التقدم هذه لنضع
الامور في سياقها نحن نتحدث هذه المسافه
من هنا الى
هنا عند اقرب خط حوالي كر و200 متر كر
ونصف حسب نوع الالتفاف بالتالي وهذه
المناطق بالاصل نحن نتحدث ان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كانت تضع منطقه ممنوع
الاقتراب منها بحدود 1 م هذه هي هناك قدره
سريعه للتوغل في هذه المناطق كنا دوما
نتحدث عن المناطق الزراعيه المفتوحه هذا
الكيلومتر والكيلومتر و2 متر هي من
المناطق المفتوحه الى حد الوصول الى اطراف
الشجاعيه اطراف هذا الحي كذلك هناك في بيت
لاهيه محاولات للتقدم هنا باتجاه مخيم
جباليا محاولات للاستهداف
لمخيم جباليا اضافه من هذه النقطه من شارع
الصفتاوي محاوله الوصول الى مخيم جباليه
والتغطيه الناريه في هذه المناطق وقصف
للمخيم مخيم جباليا من المناطق ايضا مكتظه
بشكل كبير
وبالتالي يمكن لقوات الدفاع الارتكاز في
مناطق كثيره هنا لكن هنا في هذه النقطه
كذلك يوجد مرتفع
خرائط الطبوغرافيه كانت قد اظهرت ان
الارتفاع قد يبلغ بحوالي 15 مترا في هذه
المناطق لذلك تحاول ربما قد تحاول قوات
الاحتلال الوصول الى هنا وعمل تغطيه ناريه
لكافه المنطقه الان هذا كان بالنسبه ل
الجهه الشماليه اذا ما اتجهت الان الى
المنطقه الجنوبيه ما تزال قوات الاحتلال
تحاول التوغل هنا عن طريق هذا هذا هو طريق
كيسوفيم القرارا او الجراره وبالتالي
الوصول الى ما يسمى هنا بمفترق
المطاحن وذلك لان مؤسسه المطاحن تقع في
هذه النقطه في محاوله على ما يبدو كذلك
الى
فصل هذا الجزء فصل دير البلح عن خان يونس
وبالتالي ايجاد قطاعات مختلفه جغرافيا او
على الاقل بالتغطيه الناريه هذه هي كانت
طبعا بالنسبه لقطاع غزه ابرز ما حدث خلال
هذا اليوم وسننتقل الى التحليل
العسكري معكما حسن واللواء فايز لبحث هذه
الدلالات وما هي الخطه الاسرائيليه في ضوء
هذه التطورات وايضا كيف ستكون اليات
الدفاع سنتابع بالتفصيل وبالتحليل مع
اللواء فيز الدويري كل هذه النقاط التي
ذكرتها محمود اذا سيد فايز اذا اردنا اولا
ان نتحدث عن خارطه التوغل الاسرائيلي سبق
ان توقعت ان يكون توغل الابرز هو من منطقه
الشجاعيه وهو ما حصل ما حصل اليوم
ولكن باي هدف وكيف يحصل هذا التوغل واين
نقاط تركزه يعني تحدثنا قبل بدء هذا
الهجوم بايام ام
وكان من قراءه الخارطه وقرا العقيده
القتاليه للجيش الاسرائيلي توقعت ان يكون
في هذه المنطقه هج هجومان وليس هجوم واحد
الهجوم الاول باتجاه الشجاعيه والثاني
باتجاه التفاح ولكن هو اختار ان يهاجم
الشجاعيه من اتجاهين فبالتالي هذه القوه
يمكن ان ان تلتقي على اطراف الشجاعيه
ويبقى حي التفاح احتمال قائم يبقى احتمال
قائم لكن كما تحدث محمود العمق يصل الى
1100 1100 متر وهي ارض كانت شبه اي محظور
نسبيا على
اي ابناء غزه الدخول فيها تعتبر منطقه
زراعيه رخوه هو تقدم مسافه ال000 1100 متر
لانه اذا استطاع ان ي ان ان يسيطر نعم
ويفصل بين الشجاعي والتفاح او بين الشجاعي
والزيتون يسهل عمليات القوات القادمه من
بيت لاه هي اشار لها محمود ومن ال الجهه
الش الجنوبيه الغربيه
لمخيم جباليه من منطقه الصفطاوي وبالتالي
هنا هو يحقق نوع من الاختراق العميق
الفاعل المؤثر لكن دعنا نتوقف عند
الصفطاوي ومخيم جباليا طيب في المرحله
الاولى من العمليه البريه توقف ولم يستطع
ان يحقق انجاز هذا في الشمال هذا في في
غرب مخيم جباليا وشمال الغرب مخيم جباليه
واشار الى الارض المرتفعه 15 متر تاتي من
منطقه الصفطاوي توقف بها اجبر من خلال
الهدنه على اعاده التموضع وانا قلت سيحاول
اكمال ما فشل في انجازه في المرحله الاولى
فهو اختار ان ياتي في هذه المنطقه لكن من
اجل تشتيت الجهد اندفع باتجاه الشجاعيه
كما قرانا في الخارطه قبل ان تبدا هذه
العمليه لكن دعني يشير الى نقطه قد تكون
نقطه مهمه جدا
التفاح والشجاع يوجد في لكل لكل قاطع
كتيبه
تاريخيا تعتبر هذه الكتائب هي القوه
الضاربه في قوات حماس يطلق عليها الكتائب
القوه الضاربه او القوات المميزه فبالتالي
هذه القوات ستخوض معركه عنيفه جدا ومكلفه
جدا ولا اتوقع ان جيش الاحتلال سينجح لا
في لا من جهه ال صفطاوي ولا من جهه بيت
لاهيه ولا من هذه الجهه طيب انت هنا تتحدث
عن اي عن الشمال لكن كان لافت ايضا
التصريح الاسرائيلي
بان بان الجيش لم يستطع هزيمه حماس في
مناطق الشمال باعتبار ان تضاريس المنطقه
صعبه والقتال ضاري ايضا في في تلك المناطق
طبعا هذا في مقابل ما قاله قائد
المدرعات الاسرائيليه بان العمليه في
الشمال اقتربت من تحقيق الاهداف كما كما
يقول لكن التحرك هو في اجزاء اخرى كذلك
يقول قائد المدرعات الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن
تحرك في الجنوب الان هذا التحرك يتركز في
خان يونس تحديدا طيب عند اذا اردنا ان
نوازن ما بين الشمال
والجنوب كيف يمكن ان يكون شكل وخريطه
التوا سارج ال الحديث الاخر الفشل في
انجاز المهمه في الشمال وليس الاقتراب من
انهائها لانه بناء على القسام بالامس تحدث
عن سحب 70% من القوه في
الشمال من خلال عمليه اعاده الانتشار
والتموضع وق وتحدثنا عن صور الاقمار
الصناعيه 11 14 24 نوفمبر وبالتالي لم
نستطيع ان نحدد اماكن اعاده موضعها ولكن
بما انه جاء البيان تم سحب 70% وع عندما
نقول 70% قد يبدو للمشاهد انه سحب معظم
القوه لا بقي حوالي فرقه لانه هناك ثلاثه
فرق في تقديري تم توظيفها تم سحب منها
فرقتين وتم تعزيزها من قوات الاحتياط
العملياتي والابقاء الاحتياط الاستراتيجي
فالان اتحدث عن ثلاثه فرق ذهبت الى جنوب
وادي غزه وكذلك في القراءه الاستشراف التي
تحدثنا فيها نب
عما
الج كان احد الاماكن التي تحدثت عنها
بالضبط لفصل خان يونس عن دير البلح وكذلك
سيكون خلال الايام القادمه هجوم اخر من
الجنوب الشرقي من خان يونس لفصلها عن دير
البلح وبالتالي لاحداث اختراق يسعيان لعمل
فكي كماشه على خان يونس لكن اعود الى
التاكيد على نقطه اخرى
هذه المنطقه يوجد فيها ثلاثه الويه لواء
الوسط لواء خان يونس لواء رفاح هذه
الالويه لا تزال طازجه لم تدخل في
اشتباكات بمعنى الاشتباكات بدات
الاشتباكات من صباح الامس تقريبا ولا تزال
الان هو دخل 1200 متر وصل الى شارع صلاح
الدين وهنا شارع صلاح الدين المشاهد قد
يعتبر الوصول لشارع صلاح الدين انه امر
خارق لا المسافه 6 م شارع صم صلاح الدين
يبعد 3 م دخلوا في المنطقه الرخوه طيب لكن
جمله واحده اذا ذهبنا الى الجنوب سيفاج
المشاهد ان الوصول الى شارع صلاح الدين
سيكون خلال ساعتين ليس خلال يومين لماذا
لان شارع صلاح الدين ينعطف باتجاه ال
الجنوب الشرقي ويصبح على مسافه اقل من
كيلومتر من السياج اذا هنا المسافات
البينيه قد تكون مظلله لكن دعني اقول ما
سيجري في الجنوب قد يكون اعنف واوسع
واكثر ضراوه مما جرى رغم ما جرى من ضراوه
في الشمال طيب هذا هذه الخريطه تحديدا ل
لمنطقه الجنوب خانيونس رفح هذا شارع صلاح
الدين وتلك مستوطنه كسوفين طيب لو لو
ارتفعنا نحو الشمال قليلا من جديد وهنا
اود ان اسال عن عمليه المقاومه رغم التوغل
رغم القصف في مناطق الشمال اليوم كان هناك
التحام وحتى كما تقول كتائب القسام وايضا
سرايا
القدس قصف لتجمعات اسرائيليه لدبابات
اسرائيليه وايضا الاجهاز على جنود
اسرائيليين من مسافه صفر تحديدا في
المناطق التي تقول قوات الاحتلال انها
توغلت فيها يا سيدي الان لا يوجد رغم
الدمار رغم القصف رغم كل شيء رغم ارتكاب
كل انواع الموبقات من قبل الجيش الذي يدع
بانه الاكثر اخلاقيه وهو الاكثر
اخلاقيه ليعطيني كيلومتر مربع واحد في غزه
سيطره عليها هو دخل انا لا انكر
والخارطة سنتحدث مع محمود لاعاده تفعيلها
وعمل ابديت لها لانه يجب ان يجب ان تتراجع
الى حدود المناطق المبنيه فتكون اقل حجم
المنطقه التي دخلها حتى هذه اللحظه لا
تتجاوز 18 الى 20% في منطقه الشمال كامله
اذا لما بقول
20% اذا انا عندي 80% من المنطقه الشماليه
لم يدخلها هو دخل في نقاط معينه لكنه لم
يسيطر الان اضرب مثالين طيب في اقصى
الشمال الشرقي بيت حنون وفي اقصى الجنوب
الخارطه جحر الديك اليست هي المرتكزات
الاساسيه للعمليات الرئيسيه ومعظم الافلام
التي يعرضها القسام تظهر من هذه المناطق
من ج بالامس الحديث عن 60 جندي صهيوني
والموجودين بالخيام واستخدام العبوات
الناسفه اين كانت في جحر الديك جحر الديك
متى وصلها في اليوم الاول من العمليه
البريه بيت حانون متى وصلها في اليوم
اليوم الاول من العمليه البريه طيب
بالسياق نفسه الذي نتحدث عنه الجيش
الاسرائيلي اعترف بمقتل ثلاثه جنود بينهم
ضابط في المعارك البريه مع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في شمال ووسط قطاع غزه كما كان
يذكر اللواء فيز الدويري لذل بذلك ترتفع
حصيله عدد القتلى من الجنود الاسرائيليين
الى
77 جنديا وضابطا خلال العمليات البريه
التي بدات مع نهايه الاسبوع الثاني للحرب
على غزه والتي تقترب من نهايه اسبوعها
الثامن بذلك ارتفع العدد الى 400 جندي
قتلوا منذ عمليه طوفان الاقصى والحرب
الاسرائيليه التي تبعتها على غزه في
السابع من اكتوبر الماضي والتي تدخل يومها
التاسع
وال هذه الحصيله بحسب اعترافات الجيش
الاسرائيلي لكن لكن ايضا في محطات سابقه
معك كنت تفصل بانه بان هذه الحصيله ليست
هي الحصيله الحقيقيه هي ليست هي جزء يسير
من الغله النهائيه والحصي النهائيه لماذا
اذا تحدثنا بلغه الارقام ونتحدث قبل وقف
اطلاق النار بحوالي ثمانيه ايام كان عدد
الاليات التي دمرت
363 362 اليه ولو اخذنا متوسط ما بين
الدبابه فيها 10 اذا حملت بالجنود واربعه
اذا كان طاقم وما بين النمر فيها 12
الطاقم مع الجنود المتوسط تقريبا
يكون بحدود لنعتبر اربعه مع 12 المتوسط 8م
8 في 360 الرقم واضح جدا وبالتالي انا قلت
في البدايه ومنذ بدايه المعركه اضرب رقم
الرقم المعلن عن خسائره بعشره واقسم الرقم
الذي يتحدث عن خسائر القسام على 10 وهذه
معادله البسيطه الافتراضيه في في لحظه ما
تطابقت الاعداد الرياضيه التي خرجت بها مع
تقرير اكثر من صحفي اسرائيلي تحدث بنفس
اليوم طيب بيت حنون للتاكيد بيت حنون هي
في اقصى الشمال اقصى الشمال الش وهي مظلله
بالاصفر الان كتائب القسام تقول انها
استهدفت قوات الاحتلال في بيت حنون
وخرج المقاومون من احد الانفاق حيث يتواجد
او تقول قوات الاحتلال انها توغلت ودبابات
وها موجوده في في هذا المكان ماذا يعني
عسكريا هذاي يعني عدم السيطره انا قلت لك
لا يمكن للقسام ولا غير القسام ان تمنع
دخول اليات مدرعه محميه دبابه ميركافا
اربعه تضاهي الى حد ما تشالنجر وتقارب الى
حد ما هنا تضاهي وهنا تقارب ابرامز ثلاثه
وبالتالي هذه الدبابات محميه وي تستطيع ان
ان تدخل في في هذه المنطقه لكن السؤال
دخولها بحد ذاته هل هو فرض السيطره انا
اضرب امثله في بيت حنون وجحر الديك وهي
بدايات النقاط طيب في في نقطه سيد
فايز عندما عندما يتحدث الجيش الاسرائيلي
عن الاقتراب من تحقيق
الاهداف يعني السؤال يطرح من جديد ايه
اهداف القضاء على حماس او السيطره في
المناطق المت
متوغل بها ام ماذا يعني في البدايه كان
الحديث عن ما بعد حماس وقلنا حماس فكره
ومبدا وعقيده وتجاوزنا هذه المرحله القضاء
على حماس كتنظيم عسكري قلنا لا لا يزال
الحديث مبكر جدا الصواريخ اطلقت في هذا
اليوم على تل ابيب اذا الان حماس لا تزال
قادره على اداره المعركه بنجاح يعني دعني
افرق بين
امرين غزه تعرض الى كارثه لم تتعرض لها
منطقه عبره التاريخ من التدمير الممنهج
1.9 مليون من اصل 2.2 نازحين في داخل غزه
غزه دمرت بنسبه 80% وبالتالي ما جرى من
تدمير ووحشيه واجرام لا يمكن انكاره هذا
في جانب لكن في الجانب العسكري هذا هذا
الجيش ثبت خلال 59 يوم رغم ما الحقوا فينا
من مرارات وهزائم اثبت انه لا اقول غير
كفؤ انه فاشل في اداره الحرب الى هذه
الدرجه انا اتحمل كلامي كتحليل ام عسكري
استراتيجي واعتد
بتحليلي فهذه القوه لو اعطيت لاي جيش في
العالم ليهاجم هذه المنطقه لحسمها خلال
اسبوعين هذا الجيش اصفه بانه فاشل في
اداره المعركه شكرا لك اللواء فايز دويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي